[Música]
Bienvenidos a revista digital el espacio
de análisis de redes sociales y medios
de comunicación de América Latina y el
mundo de todas las citas futbolísticas
el mundial es el más visto y también el
que más pasiones despierta con gran peso
en África hasta
Qatar llegaron cinco selecciones de este
continente senegal gana Camerún
Marruecos y túnez y más allá de la
cuestión futbolística han demostrado
tener algunas de las aficiones más
comprometidas empezamos
senegal es uno de los países en los que
más se está viviendo este mundial
Precisamente en las afueras de Dakar
está el monumento al Renacimiento
africano y allí en este emblemático
lugar es donde se reúnen los aficionados
de los Leones de teránga así celebran
los goles
[Aplausos]
pero la forma de vivirlo está cambiando
en todo el mundo y tiktok es la
aplicación por excelencia donde
compartir impresiones en ghana este
influencer llamado Ronnie baco se
viralizó después de bendecir a los
jugadores de su selección cuando sonaban
los himnos nacionales veamos
[Aplausos]
pero más allá de la pasión la copa del
mundo es un buen momento para hablar de
todo aquello que rodea al fútbol como
las relaciones entre países un buen
ejemplo fueron las palabras del
seleccionador de ghana otoado después de
que se clasificara para octavos de final
la selección de senegal
sin duda es una inspiración Estoy feliz
por senegal en primer lugar es muy muy
importante como todos saben África es sí
es un continente explotado en la
historia muchas cosas salieron mal y
fueron en nuestra contra un sentimiento
colectivo africano que se ha visto en
varios vídeos de tiktok en los que
ciudadanos de países que no participan
en la Copa del Mundo celebran las
victorias de las elecciones del
continente como esta chica egipcia que
festeja una victoria de Marruecos con
una voz en la que dice es mi sangre en
el texto del vídeo escribe que celebra
todas las victorias de selecciones
Árabes y africanas contra los países que
llama colonizadores
para ampliar sobre este tema hablamos
con Carlos bajo él es periodista e
investigador social especializado en
temas africanos y Reflexiona sobre todos
estos vídeos que están apareciendo en
redes sociales Bueno no sé si se puede
hablar de solidaridad un poco en
relación con todos estos episodios de
gente que se alegra por lo que pasa en
otros países quizás tiene que ver con
con esa ola de
renovación del panafriganismo no de un
poco de repensamiento sobre sobre el
continente y sobre las conexiones que
hay dentro del continente quizás mira en
este espacio como tan tan mundano del
fútbol también también tienen una
proyección no Y sí que hemos visto
incluso dentro de los países yo ahora
recordaba un vídeo de unos niños
Aparentemente de origen magrebí en
senegal
explicándola en una tele senegalesa el
nivel de Pues eso no de fanatismo casi
no de fanatismo en plan forofismo no
de la conexión con el país no y el resto
de usuarias senegalesas de usuarios y
usuarios generales es diciendo que
grande es nuestro país No que tiene la
capacidad para para acoger así a gente
de origen extranjera no Aunque ha habido
mucha atención a lo que sucede dentro
del continente también ha sido noticia
la celebración de personas de
ascendencia en países europeos
Especialmente cuando su selección gana a
la del propio país en el que viven por
ejemplo túnez venció a Francia y así
celebraron los tunecinos en París
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un ejemplo que no se reduce a túnez
destacada fue también la victoria de
Marruecos ante Bélgica así lo hicieron
en las noches las calles de Bruselas
[Música]
Carlos bajo también se ha referido a
este tipo de celebraciones en una
oportunidad para los países africanos de
estar en Primera Plana mediática y poder
vencer a los países que dominan
habitualmente la actualidad en asuntos
políticos y económicos
Bueno yo creo que más que una forma de
revancha simbólica creo que es más bien
una forma de reafirmación
lo hemos visto en muchos otros contextos
es decir la conexión del fútbol con la
política Es evidente prácticamente en
todos los contextos no no creo que sea
tanto revancha pero sí reafirmación no
de Bueno un motivo de orgullo
una manera de colocarse de otra manera
distinta en todo ese espacio mundo no y
lo veremos también en este mundial
seguramente No en la medida en la que
algunos países africanos consigan ir
avanzando en las rondas pues es una
manera de demostrar que pueden estar en
espacios no sé si de poder no por lo
menos de cierta hegemonía no y al final
eso ayuda a las poblaciones Pues también
a reafirmarse a aumentar la autoestima
etcétera hasta aquí esta edición de
revista digital centrada en las
vivencias de los aficionados africanos
que piden una la mayor presencia en el
Torneo al tener sólo cinco cupos de los
32 que han disputado el mundial de Qatar
Pueden seguir más contenidos como este
en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]